todo empezó en crimea y todo terminará
en crimea bolodomir selensky la
Península de crimea es el auténtico
elefante en la habitación de todas las
discusiones sobre la Guerra de Ucrania
durante años fue algo así como la Ibiza
de Ucrania ahora es la manzana de la
discordia Y es que veréis los ucranianos
quieren recuperarla pero no está nada
Claro que los Estados Unidos o Europa
les vayan a ayudar en este territorio en
concreto y ojo esto no lo decimos
nosotros lo dice el mismísimo Anthony
blinken que es el secretario de estado
de los Estados Unidos atentos Anthony
blinken desaconseja que Ucrania retome
crimea el secretario de estado de
Estados Unidos tiene miedo de que los
esfuerzos para reclamar la Península
ocupada por Rusia sean una línea roja
para Vladimir Putin habéis oído bien y
diréis por qué pues por dos razones la
primera es que a primera vista recuperar
crimea parece una Misión Imposible y la
segunda y más importante es que crimea
podría ser una razón suficiente para que
Putin pulsara el botón nuclear Y es que
veréis para los rusos esta península ni
siquiera se considera una además de
Ucrania es algo así como un territorio
aparte de hecho tanto en canciones como
en medios de comunicación o incluso en
el lenguaje popular los rusos solían
referirse a Ucrania como la Ucrania y
crimea es decir como si fueran dos
entidades completamente distintas ya es
decir que en el imaginario ruso crimea
es un territorio muy distinto un lugar
muy particular con su propio estatus
claramente diferenciado y tienen ciertas
razones para pensar así la Península de
crimea tiene su propia historia muy
distinta a la del resto de Ucrania pero
no solo eso desde el punto de vista
geopolítico es un auténtico regalito
podríamos decir que fue el auténtico
premio gordo que logró Putin en 2014 de
hecho fue el único territorio que se
anexiona sin ningún miramiento quiero
decir cuando los rusos llegaron a
Ucrania en 2014 no se anexionado
directamente el donbas al menos no
oficialmente sin embargo el kremli
considera que crimea es tan ruso como el
mismísimo San Petersburgo en resumen que
Kid quiere recuperar crimea Moscú está
dispuesta a todo para evitarlo y
Washington no tiene Claro que vaya a
tomar partido en este caso así que en el
vídeo de hoy vamos a preguntarnos Por
qué crimea es tan importante para Rusia
como podría recuperar lo Ucrania y
finalmente qué escenarios Podemos
esperar hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia
[Aplausos]
[Música]
a estas alturas creo que todos tenéis el
mapa de crimea en la cabeza sin embargo
El [__] está en los detalles por eso
antes de meternos en la historia de este
territorio vamos a centrarnos en su
geografía
la Península de crimea está habitada por
2,4 millones de personas la ciudad más
importante es sebastopol con
547.000 habitantes Ahí es donde está
ahora la sede de la flota naval de Rusia
en el mar Negro controlar este enclave
significa controlar todo el mar de azoz
y todo el norte del mar Negro de hecho
hasta 2014 Ucrania tenía 12 puertos
operativos en su costa para Rusia crimea
es vital para tener una salida al mar
Negro y el mar Mediterráneo es uno de
sus pocos puertos de Aguascalientes
además sus aguas territoriales tienen
yacimientos de gas probados por un lado
Tenemos los yacimientos de skipska al
este de la Península por el otro los del
mar de azor en este caso sería
relativamente fácil explotar este gas
porque el mar de azov es el mar menos
profundo del mundo no supera los 15
metros
pero lo más importante de crimea es que
está perfectamente protegida por su
geografía tomarla por mar es Misión
Imposible para Ucrania recordad que
Rusia tiene a toda su flota del mar
Negro por aquí y diréis pues que la
tomen por tierra verdad no tan rápido ya
os he dicho que el [__] está en los
detalles a simple vista que me aparece
una península más pero cuando nos
acercamos al istmo que une a crimea con
Ucrania encontramos al [__]
[Música]
como veis toda esta zona está llena de
lagos y zonas pantanosas en realidad
sólo hay tres puntos que conectan la
Península con Ucrania esto que veis aquí
es el istmo de perecop que tiene un
ancho de entre 5 y 7 km Rusia ya lo ha
fortificado con un sinfín de trincheras
y dientes de dragón por otro lado
tenemos la Península de chonghaar por
donde pasa una autopista rodeada por
lagos de nuevo una entrada muy fácil de
proteger finalmente tenemos la punta de
arabat otro lugar que los rusos podrían
bloquear fácilmente
[Música]
En otras palabras que entrar a crimea
por tierra es misión prácticamente
Imposible se puede hacer hombre todo se
puede hacer en esta guerra a estas
alturas no podemos ni descartar otro
golpe de estado en Rusia ni cualquier
otro escenario ahora bien entrar en
crimea sería una operación militar tan
ambiciosa como el mismísimo desembarco
de normandía pero bien Ahora que hemos
visto la geografía vamos a ver la
historia porque creedme hay muchos
detalles que necesitamos saber
tierra de invasiones
ya hemos visto que crimea es muy difícil
de invadir Sin embargo a lo largo de la
historia hay un sinfín de imperios que
lo han intentado esta península tiene
una importancia geopolítica enorme De
hecho no es casualidad que la
conferencia de yalta que para muchos
supuso el comienzo de la Guerra Fría se
celebrará en yalta que es una ciudad que
está aquí en crimea entre 1238 y 1449 la
Península perteneció al Imperio mongol
después entre 1448 y 1383 fue un kanato
subordinado al imperio otomano eso
explica que parte de la población de
crimea sean los llamados tártaros de
crimea que son musulmanes finalmente en
1783 el Imperio ruso aprovechó la
debilidad de los otomanos para invadir
este territorio Y sí en este caso
entraron a crimea por tierra de hecho lo
intentaron en tres campañas distintas
durante varios largos años consiguieron
tomarla Sí pero no sin pagar un precio
muy alto en cualquier caso los zares se
hicieron con este territorio que pasó a
formar parte de la llamada nuevo rosilla
o nueva Rusia que incluía también otras
zonas como Odessa en la actual Ucrania
desde el primer momento lores rusos
tuvieron un problema con la población
local y los tártaros eran musulmanes y
no aceptaban la autoridad de los
cristianos ortodoxos rusos por eso desde
Moscú hicieron su estrategia típica
rusificar crimea enviando población de
otras zonas pero esperad un momento
porque aquí no termina la historia
[Música]
como os hemos dicho crimea es demasiado
jugosa como para que nadie la quisiera
invadir y así es como en 1853 estalló la
llamada guerra de crimea en este caso
Rusia se enfrentó a las tropas de los
otomanos los británicos y los franceses
y diréis Pero qué pintaba Francia y
Reino Unido en esta historia pues muy
simple querían apoyar al imperio otomano
la actual Turquía para evitar el
expansionismo ruso como veis Esto del
expansionismo ruso no es nada nuevo y lo
que parecía una fortaleza inexpugnable
terminó cayendo en manos de los ingleses
y los franceses en este caso
consiguieron tomarse vastopol por mar
cierto fue una victoria pírrica porque
en este caso el cólera y la disentería
terminaron acabando con decenas de miles
de soldados y finalmente Rusia mantuvo
el territorio hasta 1917 y diréis que
pasó en 1917 Exacto la en este caso los
tártaros de crimea aprovecharon la
inestabilidad de Moscú para proclamar la
República Popular de crimea república
que duró muy poco porque enseguida los
bolcheviques la volvieron a tomar
durante las siguientes décadas Esto fue
una República dentro de la federación
rusa que a su vez estaba dentro de la
unión soviética hasta 1941 Y diréis qué
pasa 1941 pues que los alemanes la
vuelven a invadir en este caso el
ejército nazi entró por el Estrecho de
karch
pero de nuevo las tropas soviéticas la
recuperaron en este caso stalin volvió a
hacer la jugada más típica de Moscú
rusificar la zona de nuevo como
deportando 200.000 tártaros y
embrillando población rusa de otras
zonas y os preguntaréis Pero cuándo
llegó a ser crimea parte de Ucrania pues
tenemos que esperarnos hasta el año 1954
cuando el por entonces líder soviético
Nikita decidió que la Península de
crimea se fuera del ruso al soviet de
Ucrania Por qué pues por una cuestión de
pura logística la ruta más lógica para
enviar recursos a esta península pasa
por Ucrania Así que lo más Lógico es que
la zona se gestiona sedes de gif a fin
de cuentas qué más daba fuera Rusia o
fuera Ucrania seguiría siendo parte de
la unión soviética Y en este momento la
caída y la disolución de la unión
soviética no se contemplaba y así es
como crimea se convirtió en el destino
vacacional favorito de las élites
soviéticas de hecho muchos gerifaltes
del partido tenían una residencia
vacacional en esta zona y así es como
llegamos a 1991 año donde pasa lo
inimaginable la unión soviética se
disuelve y Ucrania se independiza Y qué
pasa entonces pues ahora mismo lo vamos
a ver
la Ibiza de Ucrania
[Música]
Bienvenidos a la República de kazantib
tranquilos tranquilos no se trata de un
nuevo país veréis durante años la
República de kazantib fue algo así como
la madre de todas las reinas una
macrofiesta en la playa que traía gente
de toda Europa crimea era algo así como
la Ibiza de Ucrania playas de ensueño
fiestas glamurosas y todo a precios
mucho más baratos que los de la Ibiza
original y la comparación con Ibiza no
es por casualidad Porque desde el punto
de vista político crimea era una especie
de isla en todo Ucrania si sois veterano
seguidores de visualpolitik ya sabéis
que este país estaba dividido en dos
grandes poblaciones rusoparlantes por un
lado y ucranio parlantes por el otro la
mejor muestra de esto son los mapas
electorales donde las zonas con más
rusoparlante solían ganar los partidos
más cercanos a la cultura rusa y
habitualmente más sensibles con Los
lazos con Rusia Pues bien como podéis
ver crimea siempre ha votado a partidos
que defienden más a los rusos étnicos en
esta zona casi el 95% de la población
habla Ruso y eso se nota en todas las
elecciones tanto legislativas como
presidenciales todo esto explica Por qué
las revueltas de la Europa no sentaron
especialmente muy bien en esta zona ya
que es cuando llegaron los famosos
hombrecillos verdes fuerzas rusas en
crimea Quiénes son Y de dónde vienen en
2014 Rusia envió tropas a crimea sin
identificar no llevaban ninguna bandera
y por eso se les llamó los hombrecillos
verdes es decir que Rusia invadió
militarmente crimea y celebró un
referéndum de anexión a Rusia el 95% de
la población votó a favor y aquí podemos
decir de verdad fue un referéndum
democrático
evidentemente No ahora bien es muy
razonable pensar que buena parte de la
población sí que estaba a favor de
unirse a Rusia y por supuesto los que no
estaban a favor sufrieron la clásica
represión por parte de Moscú con
torturas salvajes incluidas y diréis
están condenados en crimea con ser parte
de Rusia Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
la joya del imperio de Putin
lo primero que notaron los crimeos nada
más les invadieron los rusos fue que la
República de kazantib desapareció fin de
las raves y caída Monumental del turismo
fueron años muy difíciles para la
economía local casi todas las empresas
ucranianas que abastecían la Península
desaparecieron de un día para otro y las
sanciones de occidente terminaron por
hundir el poco movimiento empresarial
que quedaba sin embargo Putin tenía
claro que crimea era su prioridad número
uno desde entonces Putin ha vuelto a la
clásica estrategia de osificación de
Moscú 140.000 tártaros se han ido ya de
crimea y en su lugar han llegado más de
250.000 rusos pero solo eso desde 2014
Moscú ha quitado recursos a todo el país
para enviarlos a crimea sí es cierto que
los habitantes de otras zonas de Rusia
no estarán muy contentos con esta medida
pero para Putin lo más importante era
que la economía de crimea no terminara
de implosionar y que la gente no se
volviera en su contra en total han dado
más de 10.000 millones de dólares en
subsidios pero por encima de todo han
logrado sacar adelante el proyecto más
simbólico de toda la administración de
Putin el puente de
hablamos de la Joya de la corona de las
infraestructuras rusas si sois veteranos
seguidores de visualpolitik ya sabéis
que Rusia tiene un problema serio de
infraestructuras en todo el país
esencialmente en lo que concierne a los
puentes Pues bien Ahora Rusia puede
decir que ha construido el puente más
largo de Europa un puesto que hasta
entonces estaba reservado para el puente
Vasco de Gama en Lisboa el puente de
kerch une Rusia con crimea a través de
19 kilómetros de carretera con cuatro
carriles hasta 2022 lo cruzaban a diario
más de 15.000 coches este puente es el
cordón umbilical que une crimea con
Rusia y ha supuesto también un
espaldarazo a su economía
[Música]
pero no solo hablamos de infraestructura
Moscú ha convertido esta península no
una auténtica fortaleza militar y la
pregunta ahora es puede Ucrania
recuperarlo Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
[Aplausos]
la geografía un arma de doble filo
hay más de 130 ríos y riachuelos que
nacen en las montañas de crimea Sin
embargo esta península sufre de escasez
de agua desde hace años hemos dicho ya
que la geografía la convierte en una
fortaleza inexpugnable pero también la
geografía es su máxima debilidad Porque
la única forma de abastecer a crimea por
tierra es a través de las carreteras que
la conectan con Ucrania o a través del
puente de kers Pues bien ambas arterias
son relativamente fáciles de atacar de
hecho ya han sido atacadas atentos el
puente de kerch que une a Rusia con
crimea ha sido dañado tras una explosión
Pero esto no es todo recordáis que
crimea se conecta por Ucrania por muy
poquitos puntos pues uno de esos puntos
es la Península de Chon hard que está
casi tocando crimea Aquí hay un pequeño
puente por donde pasan una autopista
pues atentos Rusia dice que Ucrania ha
atacado el puente de chongar con crimea
en ambos casos hablamos de ataques muy
limitados los son relativamente fáciles
de reparar pero nos indican una cosa no
están 100% seguros Es decir desde la
posición actual Ucrania es capaz de
atacar ahora imaginando que podría pasar
si las fuerzas ucranianas se acercaran a
esta zona aún más y diréis que está
pasando pues lo cierto es que sí de
hecho buena parte de la contraofensivo
ucraniana se está centrando Precisamente
en esta región
[Música]
esto que veis aquí es la región de
zaporilla que está muy cerca de crimea
en el momento en el que hacemos este
vídeo las tropas ucranianas parecen
tener como objetivo avanzar en dirección
a melipoll si llegaran a conquistar esta
zona sería muchísimo más fácil atacar
todas las arterias que conectan crimia
para hacer algo así solo necesitan
misiles de largo alcance de hecho Esta
es una de las razones por las que
Washington todavía se resiste a enviar
este tipo de armamento pero si
terminaron haciéndolo estos misiles
podrían servirles a las mil maravillas
con esta estrategia podrían secar a
crimea tanto de agua como de otros
recursos en este caso Rusia solo podría
abastecer su precio de península por mar
lo cual les complicaría muchísimo las
cosas es casi imposible suministrar
combustible y munición en grandes
cantidades a través de aviones en otras
palabras que existe la posibilidad de
que Ucrania pueda dejar a los crimeos
sin recursos y esperar que pasen los
meses poco a poco las tropas que
protegen crimea se quedarían sin
recursos para defenderse y en ese
momento Sería mucho más fácil comenzar
un ataque por tierra ahora bien
seguiríamos Hablando de una operación de
fuerza brutal más puro estilo desembarco
de normandía Ucrania tendría que enviar
grandes cantidades de tropas sabiendo
que sacrificaría miles de vidas y diréis
es posible que veamos este escenario Sí
ahora bien Qué riesgos implicaría
el primero es que una cosa es llegar a
crimea y otra tomarla por completo
recordad que hablamos de una zona en la
que siempre ha habido un sentimiento
ruso bastante fuerte además durante ocho
largos años Putin se ha encargado de
rusificar esta zona conciencia tanto con
represión como con ayudas económicas y
también enviando a decenas de miles de
colonos En otras palabras que crimea no
es jarkid y es muy posible que la gente
no reciba las tropas ucranianas con los
brazos abiertos ahora Bien también es
muy probable que no pongan resistencia
ya hemos visto como los rusos de
rost-stop del Don no movieron ni un solo
dedo cuando pasaban los tanques de
Wagner el segundo riesgo al que
podríamos enfrentarnos es el que
decíamos al principio del vídeo si Putin
B que crimea está a punto de caer quién
sabe quizás podría llegar a pulsar el
botón nuclear contra Ucrania La pregunta
es de verdad es capaz de hacer algo así
por un lado estaríamos hablando de un
auténtico órdago que tendría
consecuencias catastróficas no solo por
la respuesta de occidente sino por sus
alianzas con China y otros países Por
otra parte visto el poco control que
tiene Putin sobre su propia gente no
está del todo Claro si sus gener la
orden visto lo visto ni siquiera podemos
asegurar que no se vayan a sublevar
antes pero ahora hay otra gran pregunta
puede permitirse Ucrania olvidarse de
crimea Pues por poder podrían Pero sería
muy difícil
[Música]
mientras crimea sigue siendo parte de
Rusia nadie podrá dormir tranquilo aquí
incluso Aunque firmaran la paz con Rusia
pensad que Moscú controlaría el mar de
azov y podría cortarle el paso a las
exportaciones de grano desde puertos tan
importantes para Ucrania como el damario
Paul overdians en caso Claro está de que
se llegarán a recuperar además Rusia
mantendría una base militar perfecta
para volver a vivir Ucrania esta vez
desde el sur y aquí llegamos al Gran
dilema de crimea a Ucrania no le
conviene que siga siendo Rusia pero a la
vez de recuperarla es muy caro posibles
solución un escenario bastante probable
es que se termina negociando un estatus
especial es decir que en una hipotética
negociación de paz crimea termine siendo
una República independiente y
desmilitarizada y rusa ni ucraniana en
el medio en cualquier caso ahora la
pregunta es para vosotros creéis que
Ucrania va a intentar tomar crimea
militarmente o se terminará negociando
un estatus especial para esta península
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
Que aquí en visualpolitik sacamos vídeos
nuevos Todas las semanas así que
suscribíos este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un saludo y hasta
pronto
[Música]